AT THE CAMERA.
♪.
GREG: PREPARED TO GET BACK TO
WORK, LET’S PONDER THE
OBSTACLES, I COUNT THREE SO FAR,
FIRST THE MEDIA TO CAPTURE THEIR
ESSENCE COMPLETELY, LET’S ROLL
THE QUESTION.
>> THE AMERICAN PRESIDENTS MOVE
IS MORE AMERICAN OVER THE COURSE
OF SIX WEEKS THEN THE ENTIRETY
OF THE VIETNAM WAR?
>> SO YEAH WE LOST A LOT OF
PEOPLE BUT IF YOU LOOK AT
ORIGINAL PROJECTIONS 2.2 MILLION
MILLION, WERE PROBABLY HEADING
TO 60000 - 70000, FAR TOO MANY,
ONE PERSON IS FAR TOO MANY FOR
THIS.
GREG: GREAT ANSWER BUT AN
ASININE QUESTION.
DOES A LEADER DESERVE TO BE
REELECTED AFTER A TRAGEDY
STRIKES.
THAT’S WHAT THE ELECTION IS FOR
YOU DOPE, HE DESERVED TO BE
REELECTED AND YOU CAN APPLY THE
NON-LOGIC JUST ABOUT ANYWHERE.
A TORNADO KILLED THE JOHNSON
FAMILY ON MAIN STREET AND
MR. SMITH DELIVERS THE HE
RESIGNED FROM THE UNITED STATES
POSTAL SERVICE.
AS LONG AS THE MEDIA HAS NO
POWER IN SELF REFLECTION, THOUGH
NEVER LEARN AND KEEP MAKING
NEUROTIC OBSERVATIONS LIKE THIS
CHAT.
>> AFTER WE GO TO BREAK THERE’S
A GOOD THING ABOUT THE SECOND ON
THE CRISIS, IT’S IN THE CLEAN
AIR AND BE AS WE HAVE NOT SEEN
FOR A LONG TIME.
GREG: RAIN NOT REMARKABLE ANALYS
PRESENTS ECONOMIC TURMOIL WITH
AWESOME VISUALS FOR THE CARBON
BELCHING TV NETWORK.
IMAGINE CHUCKIE HOW BETTER THE
ENVIRONMENT WOULD BE IF THE
NETWORKS ALSO STOPPED WORKING.
SOMEHOW I DON’T THINK HE THOUGHT
THAT THERE.
FINALLY HOW IS THIS FOR
QUESTION,.
>> WILL YOU PLEDGE NEVER TO LIE
TO US FROM THE PODIUM.
>> I WILL NEVER LIE TO YOU, YOU
HAVE MY WORD ON THAT.
GREG: WHAT KIND OF ANSWER DID
THIS GRANDSTAND ARE EXPECT.
CLEARLY THE QUESTION WAS ONLY
ASKED TO GET HEADLINES FOR
HERSELF, SHE’S NOT JUST
GRANDSTANDING, SHE’S THE WHOLE
DAMN STADIUM.
WHAT DO YOU EXPECT FROM THIS
CREW AS WE GET BACK TO WORK,
WERE QUARTERBACKING AND
QUESTIONING THE TIMES, THE RISK
AND SO ON, WHICH IS FINE, IF
THERE’S A PROBLEM THEY WILL FIND
AND PITTED ON YOU KNOW WHO, NOT
THE CHINESE OF COURSE, WHO NEEDS
RED CHINA WHEN YOU ORANGE
GODZILLA.
SO FOR THE MEDIA AND AS HUMANS,
LET’S INTRODUCE GREG UP FELT
LAW, IF YOU CONTRIBUTE NOTHING
AT THE TIME OF THE EVENT, YOU
CANNOT POINT FINGERS IN THE
FUTURE.
IF YOU KNOW SUGGESTIONS I WENT
TO GO BACK TO WORK OR WHEN TO
SHUT DOWN THE ECONOMY OR WHEN TO
SHUT DOWN TROUBLE OR NOT ANY OF
NO EVIDENCE THAT YOU EVER SET
THE CONTRARY, TAKE YOUR FUTURE
ANALYSIS AND SHOVE IT UP YOUR
ASS.
IF YOU HAVE NO SKIN IN THE GAME,
NO PLACE AT THE TABLE, THEN
THERE’S THE NEXT OBSTACLE, THE
POLITICIANS WHO HAVE COURSE ARE
GOING TO POLITICS.
EXCLUDING REAL PROBLEMS FOR
THEIR OWN POLITICAL SURVIVAL,
EVERY DEMOCRAT WILL BLAME FOR
THE PANDEMIC, ADAM SCHIFF WILL
LEAD THE WAY ALREADY ANNOUNCING
HE’LL HOLD A COMMISSION WHICH IS
HILARIOUS GIVEN HIS OTHER
MISADVENTURE, THE IMPEACHMENT
PROCEEDINGS ALLOWED THE OUTBREAK
TO TAKE US BY SURPRISE.
I WON’T SAY ADAM HAS BLOOD ON
HIS HANDS BUT IF YOU ARE
UNDERWATER, HE’D BE MISTAKEN FOR
A LOBSTER.
FLATTEN HIM AND HE MAKE A
TERRIFIC SUNSET.
THEN OF COURSE THERE’S HILLARY,
SUDDENLY APPEARING AS JOE BIDEN
AND LOADS LIKE A DROOLING
VULTURE EYEING A DESICCATED
HIKER.
SHE PRETENDED TO BE AT HIS
VIRTUAL TOWN HALL TO ENDORSE JOE
BUT REALLY WAS AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR HER TO KNOCK TRUMP WHO
HUMILIATED HER IN 2016 WALL
HOPING OBVIOUSLY FOR A REMATCH.
BUT YOU KNOW, I THINK BIDEN DID
A PRETTY GOOD JOB, CHECK IT OUT.
>> HEY THERE GREEN SHIRT LADY, I
LIKE GREEN, IT’S LIKE YELLOW AND
BLUE BUT COMBINED.
IT’S GENIUS.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH JOE, IT’S
A REAL PLEASURE TO BE HERE WITH
YOU.
>> I WISH YOU WERE HERE IN
PERSON GREEN SHIRT LADY.
I BEEN BEEN WATCHING THE WEST
WING, 154 EPISODE STRAIGHT.
>> THAT IS NOT ONLY DISGRACEFUL,
IT’S SO OUTDATED, IT’S
OPPORTUNISTIC.
GREG: TAKE IT EASY GREEN SHIRT,
TB PRESIDENTS ARE COOL
ESPECIALLY MARTIN, HE HAS THAT
VOICE, NICE HEAD OF HAIR, MAYBE
WE OUGHT TO GO WITH HIM INSTEAD
OF ME.
>> THINK OF WHAT IT WOULD MEAN
IF WE HAD A REAL PRESIDENT, NOT
JUST SOMEBODY WHO PLAYS ONE ON
TV.
>> ALL RIGHT.
HOW ABOUT MOVIES THOUGH, DO YOU
REMEMBER WHEN BILL PULLMAN SAVED
US FROM ALL THE ALIENS.
I BET HE WOULD BE WILLING TO DO
THAT AGAIN.
IMAGINE THE DIFFERENCE THAT
WOULD MAKE.
>> I KNOW WHAT A DIFFERENCE IT
WOULD MAKE BECAUSE I’VE BEEN
THERE, I SEEN FIRSTHAND WHAT
PRESIDENTS CAN AND SHOULD DO.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT PRESIDENTS CAN
AND SHOULD DO, COCAINE.
THAT WILL GET YOU GOING.
JUST KIDDING LADY, STAYING IN
SCHOOL KIDS, DON’T DO DRUG.
GREG: AND THIRDLY, THERE IS THE
DISEASE ITSELF, GOING FORWARD
EVERY DECISION HAS A RISK, STAY
HOME INDEFINITELY, PEOPLE
SUFFER, GO BACK TO WORK IN THE
DISEASE COULD RETURN, WE TALK
THIS OUT BEFORE, WERE SMART
ADULTS, WE CAN BE TRUSTED, WE
FUND THE CURVE LIKE PROS, NOT
BAD FOR A FIRST TIME EVER, IT’S
A LESSON FOR ALL YOU UNDERGRADS
TAKING COURSES ON AMERICAN
HISTORY WHERE YOUR FEEBLE
PROFESSORS PORTRAY THE COUNTRY
AS IMPRESSIVE, GREEDY, IT’S ALL
BS.
THIS EVIL CAPITALIST SOCIETY PUT
THE ENTIRE SYSTEM IN JEOPARDY IN
ORDER TO SAVE THE SICK, THE
WEAK, THE OLD, EVEN SWEDEN
DIDN’T DO THAT, ARE THEY THE
MODEL FOR PROGRESSION
COMPASSION.
I DO LOVE THEIR FISH.
THE PRESIDENT’S ECONOMIC
RECOVERY TASK FORCE RELEASED A
STUDY PREDICTING THAT A FAST
REOPENING WILL IN AMERICA’S
RECESSION WITH A QUICK RECOVERY
IN THE FALL.
I KNOW THIS BECAUSE I READ IN
THEIR PRESS RELEASE GREAT I HOPE
THEY ARE RIGHT, I THINK WE ALL
FEEL LIKE RATHER BASEBALL GAME
IN THE 15th INNING AND WE JUST
WANT THIS DAMN THING TO END.
INSTEAD YOU DON’T WANT TO GO
HOME, YOU WANT TO LEAVE HOME AND
GO TO WORK.
WHICH REMINDS ME, I HOPING A
LITIGATION SHIELD WILL BE
ATTACHED TO THE BAILOUT SO
COMPANIES CAN GET BACK TO WORK
WITHOUT WORRYING THAT THEY MIGHT
GET SUED BY A GUY WHO CLAIMS HE
GOT THE CORONA FROM YOUR
BARSTOOL.
FACT IS, YOU’RE NOT GONNA
RESTART CIVILIZATION EVER
LAWYERS ARE IN THE ROOM.
IMAGINE IF THEY WERE PRESENT
ANOTHER WORLD DEFINING MOMENTS.
YOU THINK HE WOULD’VE DISCOVERED
AMERICA, NO WAY SINCE THE 15th
CENTURY RALPH NADER WITH THE
AWFUL WORKING CONDITIONS IN
THOSE SHIFTS.
YOU THINK BEN FRANKLIN WOULD’VE
BEEN TIED TO ELECTRICITY WITH
THE KITE, WHERE THE HELL IS HIS
PERMIT AND HIS HELMET ALTHOUGH
HE LOOKS LIKE HE’S WEARING ONE
AND FORGET DISCOVERED
PENICILLIN, THINK OF THE MOLD,
THE ALLERGIES, SO MAYBE LET’S BE
REASONABLE, WE ARE ALL TRYING,
WERE ON THE SAME TEAM SO WHILE
WE ALL GO BACK TO WORK, MAYBE
LAWYERS TAKE HALF DAYS, CHILL
OUT, CATCH A MOVIE BECAUSE
THERE’S GOOD NEWS COMING, WE ARE
PROMISING DRUGS, FLATTENING
CURVES, NEW HYGIENE PRACTICES
AND GOOD PEOPLE LIKE YOU DOING
GREAT THINGS.
THAT’S THE REAL WEAPON, COMPUTER
MODELS NEVER FACTOR IN HUMAN
INGENUITY.
IT CAN’T BECAUSE HUMAN INGENUITY
IS IMPOSSIBLE TO PREDICT EXCEPT
THAT YOU KNOW IT WILL BE THERE
WHEN THE GOING GETS ROUGH.